Hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide. Today I'm going to be
showing you how to renew a bond uh
within two weeks um by only playing like
10 or 15 minutes every day. It's really
simple and the answer is farming. It's
not a brand new discovery. It's
something that everyone does all the
time, but a lot of you have asked me
this question over and over again. So, I
thought I'd make a guide about it. It's
going to be how to get to uh level 32
farming and how to farm in ours and how
to do a basic farm run with next to no
requirements. Okay, let's get started.
Okay, so now for the requirements, you
are going to need about 30 to 40 combat.
Not required, but it makes this so much
easier. Um cuz there's a couple bosses
you have to fight in the quest and
having a combat level is kind of
important. Uh you'll need 31 crafting as
well um for the quest. 36 wood cutting
is another requirement and 25
construction is so we can move your
house to Za uh which I'll explain a
little bit in a minute. Uh but it is
part of the farm run. As for quests that
are required, you're going to need
Priest and Peril, uh Nature Spirit,
Fairy Tales part one, and Lost City. All
pretty easy quests. Really don't take
longer than 20 or 30 minutes. So now for
a quick rundown on how to get 32
farming. It's pretty simple. Uh to get
to level 18, you're going to do fairy
tales part one. And you have to do this
quest pretty much to do this method. I
would highly recommend doing it because
without it, the farm runs will not be
nearly as
effective. Um from there, at 18, you
start doing oak trees. Um so basically,
you're just going to apply what uh how I
do the farm run in this just to the oak
patches, which I'll put a link into the
description where the tree patches are
along with fruit trees as well. At level
27, uh, you're going to add on apple
trees. You're not swapping them out, so
you're going to be doing both of them at
the same time. And then that'll get you
to level 32. Um, honestly, will probably
take two days, maybe one day, of just
farming. It's really not that hard, but
be prepared for it just to take a day or
two to actually get your farming level
up to 32. Uh, the alternative is you can
do a bunch of quests. Um, but the
majority of you do not like questing.
So, it's really not hard to get your
farming level up. Just do it and you'll
be the 32 uh before you know it, pretty
much. So, now that you've gotten the
required farming level, this is how you
do the run. It's really not hard. Um,
I'm starting Edgeville and we're going
to withdraw the items that uh we have
gained through the quest. The main one
being the magic secretaries as well as
the
dram. So, we have our bank kind of
arranged in a row like this. So we can
easily just withdraw each of the items
systematically. So we got the secretars,
the dram staff. You're going to need a
rake, a spade, a seed dimmer, seed dber,
sorry. Uh teleport to Camelot, as well
as a teleport to your house, uh which
you've moved to Za, uh which you can do
at any of the housing agents in Verac or
other places. You're going to need five
renar seeds, um any weight reducing
equipment you want, uh amulet of glory,
a combat
bracelet, you're going to need five
super
composts, and I like I said, the
teleports. I'm just using runes to
actually have the magic level. I know
it's a lot of items, but um you'll get
used to it eventually, and it's not too
hard. So, we're going to start by
equipping our Draymond staff, and we're
going to go to the nearest Fairy Ring
network, which there's one just over
here to the right of the Edgefield bank.
Um, what you're going to need to do is
teleport to the Fairy Ring
ALQ. Um, which you actually notice I
have it on my quick hop or no, it's not
in the clip actually. Uh, but you can
get on the click quick hop. So, all you
have to do is right click and then hit
what your last teleport was. Uh, but I'm
just going to go in here, go to
ALQ, and it's going to teleport you
pretty close to the patch, actually,
just a little bit south. Uh, so you're
just going to run a little bit north and
uh run up to the patch. Uh, so all
you're going to do is uh rake the patch
since you'll probably have some freaking
leaves on it. Uh, once you're done that,
all you have to do is use the super
compost on the patch and then use your
seed on the patch. That is it. Um, it's
pretty simple. Not a lot of things you
need to do. Um, super compost on the
patch, seed on the patch, and then
you're just going to come back in 80
minutes to each of these patches and
harvest the Renars. And um, there we go.
So, we're going to go to all the other
places and show you where the other
patches are. So, next we're just going
to use our Emin of Glory to teleport to
Drainer. Um, this is one of the closer
early game teleports to the uh, I guess
the validor patch, you'd call it. It's
just a little bit south of Fidor. And
surprisingly, Drraanor is actually
closer than the Fidor teleport, just by
a little bit. So, all you're going to do
is run west along this road here, uh,
north through the cabbage patch, and it
should be right there. Same process.
You're just going to use the super
compost on
[Music]
the patch, the herb patch, and then seed
on it. So, it's same thing for all the
patches. Um, and you're going to use the
glory to get to this one. And next we're
going to use the combat bracelet and
we're going to go to the ranging guild.
Now, um, if you use skills necklaces,
it's actually a little bit quicker to go
to the fishing guild. Um, but this is
just pretty much just as quick and I use
combat bracelets a little more than the
skills necklace. But all we're going to
do is run south along this road a little
bit and it should be right down there.
Um, if you have the Ardune cloak, uh,
you can tell we're pretty much right
here as well, but that has a much higher
requirement. Um, so thing, same thing.
We're going to plant our crops here, and
we'll move on to the next, uh, patch.
So, next up, we're going to teleport to
our house, uh, which we have plopped in
Za. Uh, like I said, you just go to any
of the housing agents, and you can move
it here for like 10k or something. Uh,
and this is why we needed the 25
construction. Uh because all the rest of
the teleports in Za are decently high
level or have higher requirements. So
this one's definitely the easiest to
get. 25 construction really doesn't take
that long. And yeah, you're just going
to run east along here for a little bit
and we'll reach the patch in no time.
It's just uh where all these sand crabs
are. I don't know if you ever train
there. Pretty sweet training. Um but
yeah, there we go. Uh at this patch,
we'll rake the herbs and plant our
crops. Okay, and last up is going to be
Camelot. And um I don't know if I
mentioned it, but if you don't have the
magic level, you can use teleport tabs.
You'll use a little bit more money, but
it's not a super big deal or anything.
Uh from Camelot, you're just going to
run over here to the east. It's really
not that far. If you have the Luna spell
book for any reason, you can actually
teleport right to Catherby. Uh but
otherwise, just go to Camelot, run to
the east, and there we go, guys. That is
it. honestly only takes about five
minutes and
um does not require anything actually
for the teleports except for uh 25
construction for um yeah teleport to
house and as well as the fair ring
teleports. So we are back and this is
not what you want to see but that means
the herb is done. Um so it's dead. Uh so
we'll clear it. Uh, but for whenever
you're harvesting a herb, make sure you
have the magic sectors on
you. Um, so yeah, that's not ideal, but
it happens probably like 1/8 of the
time, I think, is what the rate is, but
um, we'll plant some more seeds anyway,
and we'll go to the next patch. Okay,
the fouled patch. So, our herb actually
grew, uh, successfully here. Uh, so
we'll pick it. So now without the magic
secretars you are only guaranteed like
three or four herbs but with them you
are guaranteed at least five and you can
get upwards of like 12 sometimes. Um
this time we got six. So I mean not
awful. We'll plant it again. And one
other interesting trick that someone
told me recently is this tool
leprechaun. If you use your grimy herbs
on him he will note them for you. Uh
which is pretty convenient uh since it
gets rid of the weight on top of the
fact that um you don't have to bank
anymore. Okay, from the second patch, we
are going to get
four. Five. Just five. So, nothing
spectacular, but we don't need
spectacular. We just need our crops not
to die pretty much.
Four.
Five.
Six. Seven. Oh we ran out of room.
That's why you want to always note your
stuff.
Um, so we have seven so far. Let's see
how many we get. pick eight. So, that's
pretty decent. And plant another seed.
And off to the last patch. And now, this
may seem a little self-explanatory, but
obviously you want to bring more seeds
to plant with you when you do the run.
Uh cuz it's just inefficient if you're
just going to go do go back twice just
to plant the seeds. And that's it, guys.
That is the full run. Really easy to do.
I know it's a little complicated at
first, but you'll get used to it
quickly. And uh yeah, we ended up with
about 25 herbs. So, not too bad. So, now
that we have completed a full farm run,
how many of these do you have to do a
day to actually renew your bond every
two weeks? And the answer is two. Uh you
want to do at least two. Uh so, that
breaks down to I normally get about 800
to 900k profit per 40 seeds that I do.
And I've done that quite a few times
now, so it's decently accurate. Um, so
that breaks down to about 20k in profit
per
se. Uh, a bond being about 3 mil right
now, that's about 150 seeds you have to
farm in two weeks. If you're doing about
10 a day, which is two runs a day, that
breaks uh, pretty well 150, give you 140
at least, which would be relatively
close. I would recommend at least doing
three runs a day. That would uh, end up
with 4.5 mil roughly at the end of the
twoe period. So, you'd end up with some
bonus cash. Uh, but doing two runs a day
would be enough to pretty much uh
sustain a bond uh indefinitely. So,
really easy to do. And uh yeah, hope you
guys enjoyed. If you did, uh the
subscribe button will be on screen.
Please hit it because it really actually
makes my day when you do. And I'll see
you guys in the next episode.
[Music]